amy thank you for being with us i just
finished watching the docu-series
and of course i have so many questions
for you uh but
first what made you want to speak out
was there anything you wanted to get
across about your experience because i
would imagine it's not easy for you to
bring all this back up in your head
the real the only reason i really did
you know this interview with netflix is
because
it had integrity you know they were
gonna it was explained to me that they
were gonna really
do the research and tell the real story
a hotel with a notorious past
is the site of another bizarre case
elisa lam from vancouver canada
is missing the big unanswered question
is
where is she i mean there have been so
many pieces on this
over time and i have not really watched
any of them just because they're not
based or not they're not talking to
anybody that worked at the hotel i mean
these are all theories and
so to me the way it was explained is
that they were actually going to do
their homework and tell the story and i
and i believed them and that's that's
why i did it you're great in it by the
way
you really help make the narrative easy
to understand and you're so
relatable um what was the biggest
misconception or maybe there was more
than one that you did
hope this would get across that has been
misconstrued over the years the mystery
you know i mean people became obsessed
you know quickly after
you know elisa lam passed away you know
people became obsessed with
you know what happened her even after it
was you know
released of you know how it was
determined how she died and
it was all very public we we know that
it was all very public
but people just couldn't seem to accept
the outcome you know and to me i feel
the the piece
puts it all together and it considers
all the circumstances they're talking to
all these different groups you know and
i i think the outcome is
the truth one thing i wondered from you
was i think at some point you say
something like
80 deaths happened while you were there
yeah and that's another thing i've been
talking a lot about actually this
morning
you know when i first started working
there there were you know a lot of
long-term tenants i mean let's just say
you know maybe over 80
you know and there were a lot of older
people and you know these
these deaths weren't murders you know
these were you know people that just
passed away
naturally i mean of course we had you
know some
you know circumstances where people lost
their lives you know due to suicide and
overdoses you know but for the most part
i mean these were older people that
you know that passed away yeah the
docu-series does get into things like
that the night stalker had spent some
time there it
the hotel does have such history to it
did you ever have any
paranormal experiences any senses there
yeah everybody keeps asking me that and
you know it's it's a great question
you know i mean i do believe in ghosts i
i do and i'm not opposed that
they don't you know that they exist but
it wasn't my experience at the hotel i
mean i
i was running the hotel we were running
a business um
you know the thought of like the ghosts
and goblins running around i mean that's
what i kind of picture with a lot of
these you know
a lot of these other things that have
been out where it's like you think that
you know they're flying around
everywhere and it just wasn't my
experience
so given though that there were
deaths happening at the hotel that it
wasn't a seedy area what made you
stay working there so long i loved my
job
i did i you know i worked with amazing
people i mean still
you know i talked to a lot of these
people still today i mean there was so
many employees that have been there 10
to over 30 years i mean 1 35 years
um we had a great team and i learned so
much while i was working there you know
it was my first hotel job
i mean it was quite an introduction but
but i i enjoyed it and in fact you know
the only reason i left is because the
hotel closed
well it seems like in you know in this
documentary we really are like you said
doing the research uncovering some
things
you at one point say i've never said
this before but
elisa she did kind of say some wild
things and and she
seemed like something was a little off
had you shared that with the police why
had you
not said it publicly before i've never
spoken publicly
at all about my experience at the hotel
my
my work everything that i shared on you
know the show
of course was shared with the police i
mean there wasn't anything that i you
know held back or anything like that i
just had never spoken about it
it's fascinating to watch you also have
to remember like you said
you know these are real people these are
real emotions and
and you guys all went through so much
what was that time just like for you
personally mentally emotionally
it was really hard you know i mean you
know beginning with you know
a human you know it was a loss i mean
somebody passed away you know in
a tragic way you know the circumstances
of you know just you know discovering
how she died and
in processing all that was you know hard
it was hard on our entire team
you know and also again you have to
remember i mean i was the general
manager so
you know i was responsible for making
sure that our employees were getting
through the process and all that i mean
there wasn't anything easy about it
so that moment when you learned of her
disappearance
what goes through your mind you know i i
didn't
from the beginning when i when i learned
that lisa lam went missing i i didn't
have a good feeling about it but i
didn't
think that she was going to end up at
the hotel i really thought you know
since she was traveling alone maybe
there was a possibility that she
you know maybe met some people you know
in you know that part of town and you
know
maybe that happened you know i i just
would have never thought you know of
course the outcome
i mean how could you possibly predict
something like that
what about the elevator video that that
is a question i still have people wonder
are there pieces missing from it
is it edited where's this missing minute
what do you say to all that
it's absolutely unedited i mean i i
handed everything over firsthand i'm the
only one that would have had access to
to the footage so i mean i i just see
that in the documentary where they they
talk about that and
absolutely not i mean we you know we we
were very transparent with the police
and
you know the the footage you know i
don't think anybody could deny is
you know it's strange of course i mean
she's she's acting very you know strange
on on the video
um but as far as like any tampering or
you know a missing minute i
i i just i don't know so is there a
minute missing from it
i i mean i saw that in the documentary
where you know people are thinking like
you know
has this been tampered with or you know
absolutely not
no there was also this other hotel guest
who was
a a singer kind of a metal singer and he
had some really
dark themes in his music and he speaks
out in the documentary
what did you think when you heard that
people were suspecting him were you
aware that online people were tracking
him down
i was absol that was i was absolutely
shocked but you know
i felt so sorry for him you know i mean
it's so clear
you know that he was you know deeply
affected by this and you know i think
you know bullying would apply you know
and this this
this guy had absolutely nothing to do
with it and you know
he was tormented well
what would you say to people who did
do all that digging all those years is
there anything you wish you could have
said at them
said to them at the time i don't know if
you spoke out at all to them at the time
when people were digging and coming to
the hotel and filming and all that
it was never a mystery for me you know i
mean i was obviously extremely involved
you know with
the whole process you know from start to
finish i mean there was never
a mystery of you know how elisa lim you
know died
for me so i think this is a great
opportunity because
you know you're you're gonna you're
gonna see they're gonna walk you through
and all the
other elements are also included but you
know there's an underlying
story and an outcome too with this with
this documentary
um if you can take me back to that
moment and when you find out
that her body is in the water tank it's
shocking
what was it like for you when you
learned about that
i mean equally as shocking i'll never
forget you know what meeting with the
health department you know i am
the health department in my in my office
and and i explained you know what it
happened and they were equally a shock
too you know they had never
dealt with anything like that before i
mean it was it was hard to process there
was
you know and i was drinking the same
water i mean i you know i
you know we were all drinking the same
water can i
what did the health department tell you
to do what what did you have to do after
that
oh we did every everything they asked us
to do i mean they did you know a series
of testing
and you know um you know the water
wasn't contaminated you know come to
find out and i guess that isn't uncommon
based on the circumstances
um there were there were a lot of steps
we had to close the hotel together
you know and relocate everybody that was
there i mean there was a lot involved
what do you hope people take away from
the series if anything what do you want
them to walk away with
i i just hope their their questions are
answered you know and at the end of the
day i hope there's healing for everybody
you know i mean
um you know at the end of the day
somebody passed away here and uh
you know it i i think that uh it will
answer a lot of questions